We're in Danielle's house. Ever since she was a girl, when holidays dinners come they serve a meal that will probably look familiar to you. Picture, please, a main course, big platter, drumsticks, white breast meat, golden brown skin, stuffing and gravy and cranberry relish on the side. And in Danielle's family, they have a name for this meal that she told me on the phone recently. The name for this meal is--
我们在丹妮尔的家里。从小到大，每逢节假日晚餐，她们家端上桌的菜你可能很熟悉。请想象一下：主菜是一大盘鸡腿、白嫩的胸肉、金黄酥脆的表皮，再配上填料、肉汁和蔓越莓酱。在丹妮尔家里，这道菜有一个她在电话里告诉我的名字。这道菜的名字是——
Fish.
鱼。
Got that?
听明白了吗？
Fish.
鱼。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. Special program today on the wonders of fish. All right, actually we can say the word here. And the word is poultry. And, as you probably know, each week on our program, we choose some theme, invite a variety of writers and performers and documentary producers to tackle that theme. And this week, as we, all of us, stand in that magical five-week period, that magical interregnum between the turkey of Thanksgiving and the turkey of Christmas, that magical five weeks where Americans consume nearly a fourth of all the turkey we consume over the course of the year, 67 million turkeys. So in this period, we bring you our annual Poultry Slam, stories about turkeys, chickens, ducks, fowl of all kind, and their mysterious hold over us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》。今天我们要播出一期关于鱼之奇迹的特别节目。好吧，其实我们这里可以说出来。那个词是家禽。正如你所知，我们每周都会设定一个主题，邀请各类作家、表演者和纪录片制作人来探讨这个主题。本周，我们所有人正处于那个神奇的五周时期——感恩节火鸡与圣诞节火鸡之间的那个神奇间歇期，这五周里美国人消耗了全年近四分之一的火鸡，也就是6700万只。因此，在这一时期，我们为你带来一年一度的“家禽大满贯”，讲述关于火鸡、鸡、鸭和各种禽类的故事，以及它们对我们那种神秘的掌控力。
Well, I'm Ira Glass. Coming up in this hour, Act One, Duki.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。接下来在本节目中，第一幕：杜基。
Act Two, Turkey.
第二幕：火鸡。
Act Three, writer David Sedaris.
第三幕：作家大卫·塞达里斯。
Act Four, South African Chicken Blood.
第四幕：南非鸡血。
And of course, what poultry-positive program would be complete without--
当然，什么样的家禽主题节目能少了它呢——
Chickenman!
鸡侠！
He's everywhere! He's everywhere!
他无处不在！他无处不在！
Yes, indeed, in the late 1960s, the winged warrior, Chickenman, struck terror in the hearts of evildoers on radios all across our great nation. And today, we are pleased to bring you the first new episode of Chickenman since 1969. This is one of those things if you have heard Chickenman , this needs no introduction. If you haven't, you are in for a big, big treat, a big radio treat. It's later in the show. Stay with us.
没错，在20世纪60年代末，这位长着翅膀的战士——鸡侠，曾在我们伟大国家的电台里让恶人们闻风丧胆。今天，我们很高兴为你带来1969年以来的第一部鸡侠新剧。如果你听过鸡侠，这无需多言；如果你没听过，那你可有福了，这是一场广播盛宴。节目稍后播出，请继续收听。
Act One, Duki. So in Danielle's family, the power of poultry is so great in their lives that when they serve chicken or turkey, they call it--
第一幕：杜基。在丹妮尔家里，家禽的力量在她们的生活中是如此巨大，以至于每当她们供应鸡肉或火鸡时，她们都管它叫——
Fish.
鱼。
That's right. And they call it that for a reason. And the reason has to do with a stuffed hand puppet called Duki. Now Danielle is nearly 30 years old. Her sister, Ashley, is two years younger. And Duki has been in the family since they were children.
没错。她们这么叫是有原因的。这个原因与一个叫杜基的塞棉手偶有关。丹妮尔现在快30岁了。她妹妹艾什莉比她小两岁。从她们小时候起，杜基就在家里了。
Well, he was a Christmas present when Ashley was about 8, and I was about 10. And when he first arrived, he was really fluffy. And he was this beautiful, fluffy, white duck. And he had a cape on and black, villain slash hero goggles. He lost the outfit pretty quickly, and he went naked. And then he became Ashley's vehicle for torturing me.
嗯，那是艾什莉8岁、我10岁时收到的圣诞礼物。他刚到家的时候真的很毛茸茸。他是一只漂亮、毛茸茸的白鸭子。他披着斗篷，戴着黑色的反派兼英雄护目镜。他很快就弄丢了那身行头，开始“裸奔”了。后来，他成了艾什莉折磨我的工具。
Now, it's not unusual for older siblings to dominate younger ones. And as children, Danielle dominated Ashley. Ashley looked up to Danielle, fought to get her attention and her approval, and Danielle always, always got her way, except when Duki was around. Basically, Ashley would channel-- I mean the word is an anachronism in this context, but she would channel Duki. She should become Duki's voice. She would speak as Duki. And Duki was sarcastic. Duki was selfish and bossy. Duki would insult Danielle. Duki would tease Danielle. Duki would give her painful nose squeaks.
年长者主导年幼者并非罕见。小时候，丹妮尔总是压制艾什莉。艾什莉仰慕丹妮尔，争取她的关注和认可，而丹妮尔总是能随心所欲，唯独在杜基在场时例外。基本上，艾什莉会通过——在这个语境下用“通灵”这个词或许不太恰当，但她会进入杜基的状态。她会变成杜基的嗓音，替杜基说话。杜基很刻薄。杜基很自私又爱指手画脚。杜基会侮辱丹妮尔，嘲笑丹妮尔，还会给她捏鼻子，弄得很疼。
Whenever Ashley brought Duki into the equation, he was completely the dominant force. I was just putty in Duki's hands.
每当艾什莉把杜基搬出来时，他就是绝对的支配者。在杜基手里，我简直就像橡皮泥一样。
Let me ask you to compare his personality with Ashley's personality.
我请你对比一下他的性格和艾什莉的性格。
Ashley's very considerate and kind and thoughtful. And very, very sensitive to other people, very, very concerned about if other people are happy, and if someone else doesn't feel good. And Duki has this total, what's for lunch attitude. Like what's in it for me? In your face, totally out for himself, simultaneously a braggart and a total wimp.
艾什莉非常体贴、善良且善解人意。她对别人非常敏感，非常关心别人是否快乐，是否有人感到不舒服。而杜基完全是一副“午饭吃什么”的态度。就好像“我能从中得到什么？”他那种咄咄逼人的态度，完全是为了自己，同时既是个吹牛大王，又是个彻头彻尾的懦夫。
He's boastful and vain.
他自大又虚荣。
He's just this indomitable spirit.
他就是那种不屈不挠的“精神”。
Well, 19 years after Duki arrived in the Mattoon household, the fluffy whiteness is long gone. Fluffy, in fact, is not a word you would really use to describe Duki. Nor is two-eyed, if I remember correctly.
在杜基来到马顿家19年后，那种毛茸茸的白色早已消失不见了。事实上，如果你想形容杜基，你绝对不会用“毛茸茸”这个词。如果我没记错的话，也不会用“双眼俱全”来形容他。
What he looks like physically is just-- he's a slightly pathetic looking, gray, tattered thing.
从外观上看，他简直就是——一个看起来有点可怜、灰扑扑、破破烂烂的东西。
Very tattered.
非常破烂。
Very tattered. But then the fact that his brain, what's coming out of his mouth, is in complete denial about who he actually is-- I don't know. There's just something really, really great about that. And really, you have to love him for it.
非常破烂。但事实是，他的大脑，或者说他嘴里说出来的东西，完全否认了他真实的样貌——我不知道。关于这一点，真的非常非常棒。你真的不得不因此而爱上他。
All right, I've been at Danielle's apartment sometimes, and I've witnessed the following scene. Picture, please. Danielle has not spoken with her sister in weeks. She picks up the phone, calls Ashley in Michigan. Ashley answers. Danielle asks immediately, "Can you put Duki on?" And then Ashley essentially becomes Duki, puts Duki on the phone. Danielle talks to Duki for 15, 20 minutes. And then they both hang up. That's the whole conversation. And they both feel satisfied. These are adults. Danielle is an editor at a big New York magazine.
好了，我有时会去丹妮尔的公寓，亲眼见证过以下场景。请想象一下：丹妮尔已经几周没跟她妹妹说话了。她拿起电话，打给密歇根州的艾什莉。艾什莉接听后，丹妮尔直接问：“能让杜基接电话吗？”然后艾什莉基本上就变成了杜基，让杜基接听电话。丹妮尔和杜基聊上15到20分钟。然后她们挂断电话。这就是整个通话过程。她们都感到很满足。这些人可是成年人。丹妮尔还是纽约一家大杂志社的编辑。
I adore Duki. I really love Duki. And sometimes, I think if he disappeared, it would really feel like someone died. I mean, I look at him, and he looks really old and ratty, and it really makes me sad. I mean, it sounds crazy. It really makes me sad to think about a world without Duki in it. There would be a big, empty hole in the world. He takes up as much room in my heart as a lot of people individually. And if something happened to him, if he were lost at an airport or run over by a car, it would really be heartbreaking.
我爱慕杜基。我真的爱杜基。有时候我想，如果他消失了，那种感觉就像有人去世了一样。我是说，我看着他，他看起来真的很老旧、破烂，这让我感到很难过。我是说，这听起来很疯狂。想到一个没有杜基的世界，我真的会很难过。世界上会留下一个巨大的空洞。他在我心中的位置和许多人是一样的。如果他出了什么事，比如在机场丢了，或者被车压了，那真的会让人心碎。
So I hope it's becoming clear why, if you eat dinner in the home of Danielle's family, if they're serving some kind of poultry, chicken or turkey, if you were to ask anybody in the family what's for dinner, they'll tell you--
所以我想现在应该很清楚了，为什么如果你在丹妮尔家里吃晚饭，如果她们端上任何种类的家禽，鸡肉或火鸡，如果你问家里任何人晚饭吃什么，她们会告诉你——
Fish.
鱼。
Right. And the rationale for that is what?
没错。那理由是什么呢？
It freaks Duki out.
这会把杜基吓坏的。
It freaks him out-- you don't like him to know that perhaps some birds are in fact eaten?
会吓坏他——你不希望他知道可能有些鸟类实际上是被吃掉的吗？
I think he knows. I think he's in denial about it. He's in denial about most things. He's in denial about the fact that he's totally weak and tiny and dirty. He thinks he's really good-looking and strong and that he's really smart and has a lot of friends.
我想他是知道的。但我认为他在否认这件事。他否认大多数事情。他否认他其实很虚弱、渺小且肮脏的事实。他认为自己又帅又强壮，还觉得他很聪明，有很多朋友。
Right.
对。
He's in denial about the fact that he's actually stuffed, which he is. Sometimes I tell him that. I say, "Duki, give me a break. You're just stuffed." And he's like, "No way."
他否认他实际上是塞了棉花的，但他确实是。有时候我告诉他：“杜基，放过我吧，你只是塞了棉花而已。”而他会说：“才怪。”
Now, I thought I would try to book Duki to come on the radio for this program. So I contacted Danielle's sister, Ashley, and asked her, "Could Duki come on the air?" I received an answer back, not by phone, but by electronic mail, that for Duki to appear, I'd have to first go through someone named Yona Lu, who I could reach through Danielle and Ashley's mother. And when I talked to Danielle, I asked her about this.
我想我应该试着为这档节目预约杜基上电台。所以我联系了丹妮尔的妹妹艾什莉，问她：“杜基能上节目吗？”我收到的回复不是通过电话，而是电子邮件，说如果杜基要参加，我必须先通过一个叫约娜·陆的人，我可以通过丹妮尔和艾什莉的母亲联系到她。当我跟丹妮尔谈起这件事时，我问了她。
I've been informed that the only way that I can reach him is by calling your mom and speaking to Yona Lu. Do I have that name right?
我被告知唯一能联系到他的办法是打给你妈妈，找约娜·陆谈。那个名字我没记错吧？
Yona Lu, yeah. I think she's acting as his agent.
约娜·陆，对。我想她是在担任他的经纪人。
Yona Lu is?
约娜·陆是吗？
She's a hedgehog.
她是一只刺猬。
Anything special that I should say to Yona Lu to make this happen?
有什么特别的话是我该对约娜·陆说，好让她促成这件事吗？
I don't know. She drives a pretty hard bargain. [PHONE RINGING]
我不知道。她可是个很难对付的谈判者。[电话铃响]
Hello?
喂？
Hey, Mrs. Mattoon.
嘿，马顿太太。
Yes?
你好？
It's Ira Glass.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Hi, Ira Glass.
嗨，艾拉·格拉斯。
Mrs. Mattoon, here's why I called you. I want to do a little story on the radio about Duki.
马顿太太，我打电话给您是因为我想在电台做一个关于杜基的小故事。
Duki?
杜基？
Duki. And I contacted your daughter, Ashley. And she said that for me to book Duki onto my radio show, I was going to first need to contact Yona Lu.
杜基。我联系了您的女儿艾什莉，她说如果要让杜基上我的广播节目，我得先联系约娜·陆。
Yeah, you would need to do that.
是啊，你是得那样做。
And that I needed to do that through you.
而且必须通过您来联系。
Yeah.
对。
Who is Yona Lu?
约娜·陆是谁？
Yona Lu is a hedgehog. She's basically taken charge of Duki's financial affairs. And I presume this has something to do with money?
约娜·陆是一只刺猬。她基本上接管了杜基的财务事务。我猜这跟钱有关？
Well, I don't know actually. I mean, we--
嗯，其实我也不清楚。我是说，我们——
That's probably why she said to contact Yona Lu.
那大概就是为什么她说要联系约娜·陆。
Well, so what do I do now? I was told to contact you if I wanted to get in touch with Yona Lu in order to book Duki. What do I do next?
好吧，那我接下来该怎么办？有人告诉我如果想联系约娜·陆来预约杜基，得找您。我接下来该做什么？
Book Duki, OK. You're going to book Duki.
预约杜基，好的。你要预约杜基。
That's the whole idea. I want to book Duki for the show, for an interview.
没错，就是这个意思。我想预约杜基上节目，接受一次采访。
Well, I'll just talk to Yona Lu about it. She says OK, it's OK.
嗯，我会跟约娜·陆谈谈的。她说行就行。
Will Yona Lu want to discuss terms or something?
约娜·陆会想要谈条件之类的吗？
She doesn't talk.
她不会说话。
So what's going to happen? All right, should I call you back?
那会发生什么呢？好的，那我应该再打给您吗？
You could call me back. Or I just go in and check.
你可以再打给我。或者我就进去看一下。
You'll just go in and check?
您进去看一下？
Yeah.
是啊。
Should I wait?
我该等着吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
All right, I'll wait.
好吧，我等着。
Ira, this is just radio?
艾拉，这只是广播吧？
Yeah.
对。
Not TV?
不是电视？
It's just radio.
只是广播。
And nobody is going to get to be on TV?
没人能上电视吗？
No, no one's going to be on TV. No, it's strictly radio.
不，没人上电视。不，纯粹是广播。
OK, Yona Lu doesn't care what happens then.
好的，那约娜·陆就不介意会发生什么了。
What if it were TV?
如果是在电视上呢？
I think she'd want to be on too. Radio doesn't do much for her because she doesn't talk.
我想她也会想出镜的。广播对她没什么意义，因为她不会说话。
All right, as you might imagine, not everybody in the family takes all this so lightly. Danielle's father was never too keen on this.
好了，你可以想象，并不是家里每个人都对这一切轻描淡写。丹妮尔的父亲从来都不太赞成这些。
He was quite actually bothered by the whole. He thought we maybe had a problem in the family.
他实际上对这一切非常困扰。他认为我们家里可能出了什么问题。
Really?
真的吗？
Mm-hmm. I mean, for a while there, we had two daughters that only communicated through a duck.
嗯。我是说，有一段时间，我们家里有两个女儿只能通过一只鸭子进行交流。
Yeah, that period that you're describing, when do you mean?
是啊，你描述的那个时期，是指什么时候？
I would say they maybe were 10 and 12, or 9 and 11.
我想她们大概10岁和12岁，或者9岁和11岁的时候。
And they would only communicate through the duck?
她们真的只通过那只鸭子交流？
Well, Danielle didn't pay a whole lot of attention to Ashley, but she paid quite a lot of attention to the duck. So if Ashley wanted to get Danielle's attention, all she had to do was rev up the duck.
嗯，丹妮尔不太理睬艾什莉，但她非常关注那只鸭子。所以如果艾什莉想引起丹妮尔的注意，她只需要把杜基搬出来就行了。
And how long did this last?
这持续了多久？
I can't remember. She would also make Danielle laugh that way. Danielle thought Duki was very funny, but I can't remember her thinking Ashley was funny.
我不记得了。她还会用那种方式逗丹妮尔笑。丹妮尔觉得杜基很搞笑，但我记不得她觉得艾什莉也很搞笑。
In terms of the relationship between my sister and me, I don't know why-- I mean, this is probably completely really sick. But I have so much genuine affection and love for Duki that it's very easy to demonstrate those feelings in a way that it's not as easy to demonstrate those feelings toward my sister, just because we never got in the habit of it.
关于我和我妹妹之间的关系，我不知道为什么——我是说，这可能真的很病态。但我对杜基有非常真挚的爱和喜爱，以至于表现出这些感情很容易，但以同样的方式对我的妹妹表现出这些感情就不那么容易，只是因为我们从未养成这种习惯。
What percentage of your relationship with your sister is based on your relationship with Duki?
你和你妹妹之间关系的多少比例是基于你和杜基的关系的？
Well, the really fun part of it is based on my relationship with Duki, but I think as we've gotten older and older, we've gotten more and more self-conscious about the Duki factor in our relationship. But I think a big chunk. I mean, it definitely gives me this vision into her brain that I wouldn't have otherwise.
嗯，其中真正有趣的部分是基于我和杜基的关系。但我认为随着我们越来越大，我们对人际关系中的“杜基因素”感到越来越不自在。但我认为占了很大一部分。我是说，它确实让我能够进入她的思维，否则我无法做到这一点。
Well, I did finally snag an interview with Duki. You know, big network radio program that we are, we could pull off this coup, snag for you this interview with an imaginary hand puppet. Anyway, I did make this happen by calling Ashley.
好了，我最终还是拿下了对杜基的采访。你知道，作为我们这样的大型网络广播节目，我们能完成这次政变，为你搞到这次对一个虚构手偶的采访。总之，我通过给艾什莉打电话促成了这件事。
Is Duki still up for this?
杜基还愿意吗？
Yeah, he just got back from a party though.
可以，不过他刚从一个聚会上回来。
He just got back from a party?
他刚从聚会上回来？
Yeah, he was at a happy hour thing with a lot of college students. He's not in college, but he's in a band, so a lot of his friends go to this happy hour on Friday night.
是啊，他和一群大学生去参加了“欢乐时光”活动。他虽然不是大学生，但他组了个乐队，所以他很多朋友周五晚上都会去参加这个活动。
All right, well, could you get him?
好的，那你能叫他一下吗？
Sure, he's upstairs. Just a sec. Here he is.
没问题，他在楼上。稍等。他来了。
Hey, Duki?
嘿，杜基？
Yeah, hey, Ira. How are you doing?
嘿，艾拉。你怎么样？
I'm just fine.
我很好。
Long time no see.
好久不见。
Long time no see back at you. And welcome to our little radio program.
也祝你好久不见。欢迎来到我们的小广播节目。
So what's going on here? You've got a whole bunch of celebrities on tonight?
所以这是怎么回事？你今晚请了一大堆名人吗？
Well, we actually have a number of different people.
嗯，我们其实请了不少不同的人。
What about Tom Cruise?
那汤姆·克鲁斯呢？
They're just like Tom Cruise.
他们就像汤姆·克鲁斯一样。
OK.
好的。
Now, Duki, I was talking to Danielle for our radio program, and had her come on and talk about you a little bit. And one of the things that she said was that when she was younger, in order to discipline her if she was doing something that you didn't like, you could pretty much control her with something called nose squeaks?
现在，杜基，我之前为了广播节目和丹妮尔聊过，请她上来聊了聊你。她说的一件事是，当她小时候，如果她做了你不喜欢的事情，你基本上可以用“捏鼻子”来控制她？
Yeah, because it's a prominent nose. I mean, it sticks out, and you just want to squeak it. Like over Thanksgiving, we were watching The Muppet Show, and Ms. Piggy was on. And she reminded me a lot of Neelie.
是啊，因为她的鼻子很突出。我是说，它很显眼，你就是想捏一下。就像感恩节的时候，我们在看《布偶秀》，猪小姐也在里面。她让我想起了很多妮莉（丹妮尔的昵称）。
Of Danielle.
是指丹妮尔。
Mm-hmm. And Kermit told Ms. Piggy, move the pork. And so I was telling Neelie to move the pork all week.
嗯。当时科米蛙对猪小姐说：“把猪肉拿走。”所以那整个星期我都在叫妮莉“把猪肉拿走”。
And would she move?
她会听吗？
Yes, she would. She would.
会，她会的。
Now if Ashley would tell her, if Ashley would sit down on the couch and say to Danielle, "Move the pork," what would the effect of that be?
如果艾什莉告诉她，如果艾什莉坐在沙发上对丹妮尔说“把猪肉拿走”，那会有什么效果？
You know Neelie. You know how she looks at you when she doesn't approve of something you say or do? She gets this ice-cold stare, and she gives you this sidelong glance that makes you feel like you're about the size of a pea? That's what she does.
你了解妮莉。你知道当她不赞成你说的话或做的事时，她怎么看你吗？她会投来那种冰冷的眼神，还会瞥你一眼，让你觉得你就像豌豆那么大。她就是那样。
Is there anything about the life of a duck that perhaps you could tell our radio audience that we might not know? I'm sure that you know much more about it than we do.
关于鸭子的生活，有什么你能告诉我们广播听众，而我们可能不知道的吗？我相信你肯定比我们了解得多得多。
No, not really. I'm kind of an unusual duck. I'm not really in touch with the whole duck scene.
不，没什么特别的。我是只不太一样的鸭子。我其实不太接触鸭子的圈子。
You're not in touch with the whole scene, yeah.
你不太接触那个圈子，是吧。
When I had time, I used to migrate once in a while because I had some friends who were ducks. And I tried to keep in touch with them. But lately, I've just started spending more time with people and doing my own thing, and I just don't have time to do those duck things anymore. I just wanted more out of my life than that.
以前有时间的时候，我偶尔会迁徙，因为我有几个鸭子朋友。我试着和她们保持联系。但最近，我开始花更多时间陪人类，做我自己的事情，我就没时间再去干那些鸭子干的事情了。我只是想从生活中得到比那更多的东西。
Well, the story of a 27-year-old graduate student who talks like a duck naturally brings us to the story of Chickenman. Chickenman first soared the radio airwaves from 1966 to 1969. Nearly everyday, there would be a new episode. These were these short little things, each one two minutes long or so, starting on WCFL here in Chicago, but spreading to over 1,500 radio stations. Three times, by the way, that's three times the number in the public radio network. According to the people who syndicate Chickenman, it has been translated into German, into Dutch, into Swedish. It is still on the air, they say, in several dozen markets, making it one of the longest running radio features anywhere. Chickenman. Chickenman existed years before National Public Radio existed as a national network. Chickenman will continue probably years after we're all gone like the mighty cockroach, like-- I don't know-- like the bagel, like [UNINTELLIGIBLE] Chickenman endures, will endure.
好了，一个27岁、说话像鸭子的研究生的故事，自然让我们想到了鸡侠的故事。鸡侠从1966年到1969年在广播电台风靡一时。几乎每天都有新剧集。这些都是很短的小东西，每集大概两分钟长，最初在芝加哥的WCFL电台播出，后来传播到超过1500个广播电台。顺便说一下，这个数字是公共广播网络数量的三倍。据发行鸡侠的人士称，它已被翻译成德语、荷兰语和瑞典语。他们说它至今仍在几十个市场播出，使其成为历史上播出时间最长的广播节目之一。鸡侠。鸡侠在全国公共广播电台作为一个全国性网络存在之前就已经存在多年了。鸡侠可能会在我们要消失多年后继续存在，像顽强的小强一样，像——我不知道——像百吉饼一样。鸡侠永存，必将永存。
Well, coming up later in the program, we'll have the first new real Chicken episode since 1969, written especially for This American Life by Dick Orkin, the voice of Chickenman. But first, before that, let's hear what all the fuss was about.
好了，节目稍后，我们将播出1969年以来的第一部真正的鸡侠新剧，这是由鸡侠的配音演员迪克·奥金专门为《美国生活》创作的。但首先，在那之前，让我们听听大家都在忙什么。
Now another exciting episode in the life of the most fantastic crime fighter the world has ever known, Chickenman.
现在是世界上最了不起的犯罪克星——鸡侠生命中又一段激动人心的插曲。
He's everywhere! He's everywhere!
他无处不在！他无处不在！
Benton Harper, employed as a shoe salesman for a large downtown department store, spends his weekends, his only two days off, striking terror into the hearts of criminals everywhere as the white-winged warrior called Chickenman. How did it come about that Benton Harper, weekend-winged warrior, selected the visage of the chicken in his crusade against the forces of evil? Now, it can be told.
本顿·哈珀，在一家大型市中心百货公司担任鞋类销售员，他利用周末，也就是仅有的两天假，以长着白翅膀的战士——鸡侠的身份，让各地罪犯闻风丧胆。为什么周末战士本顿·哈珀会选择鸡的形象来开启他打击邪恶势力的征程？现在，答案揭晓了。
Yes, may I help you?
是的，我能为您效劳吗？
How do you do? I'm looking for a costume.
你好，我在找一套服装。
What did you have in mind?
你想找什么样的？
Something that will strike terror into the hearts of criminals everywhere.
能让各地罪犯闻风丧胆的那种。
I see, well how about this?
我明白了，嗯，这套怎么样？
No, I don't think so.
不，我觉得不太行。
Why not try it on?
为什么不试穿一下呢？
Very well.
好吧。
Here, I'll help you.
来，我帮你。
Thank you.
谢谢。
There you are. Now take a look in the mirror.
好了。现在照照镜子。
Hmm, not bad. I wonder if you would permit me to conduct a quick experiment outside this store.
嗯，还不错。我不知道你是否允许我在店外做一个简单的实验。
Certainly.
当然可以。
Pardon me, sir.
打扰一下，先生。
Yeah?
啊？
Are you by chance a vicious criminal?
你该不会是个恶贯满盈的罪犯吧？
Uh-uh.
呃，不是。
Fine, would you take a look at this costume I'm wearing?
很好，你能看看我穿的这身行头吗？
Yeah.
啊。
Do you feel anything strange? Anything at all?
你觉得有什么奇怪的感觉吗？有什么感觉吗？
Yeah.
有。
And what is that?
是什么？
I'd like to kiss you.
我想亲你一口。
Kiss me?
亲我？
Yeah.
是啊。
How do you account for that?
你怎么解释这个？
Because you look like an adorable bunny rabbit.
因为你看起来像只可爱的小白兔。
Well, how did it go?
好了，情况怎么样？
What else do you have?
你还有什么其他的吗？
A teddy bear and a chicken.
一只泰迪熊和一只鸡。
A teddy bear?
泰迪熊？
It'd be cute.
那会很可爱。
Wrap up the chicken, please.
请帮我把那只鸡包起来。
Be listening tomorrow for another exciting episode in the life of the most fantastic crime fighter the world has ever known, Chickenman.
明天请继续收听世界上最了不起的犯罪克星——鸡侠生命中又一段激动人心的插曲。
He's everywhere! He's everywhere!
他无处不在！他无处不在！
I love these. Do you want to hear another? We have time for another. You want to hear another? The thing I love is how completely low-key the performances are. It's like they're not even trying. It's a complete aesthetic. All right, let's hear one more before we continue with the next act.
我爱这些。你想听另一段吗？我们还有时间听一段。你想听吗？我喜欢的是这些表演完全不紧不慢。就好像他们根本没在刻意表演一样。这是一种完整的美学。好了，让我们在进入下一幕之前再听一段。
Now, another exciting episode in the life of the most fantastic crime fighter the world has ever known, Chickenman.
现在，世界上最了不起的犯罪克星——鸡侠生命中又一段激动人心的插曲。
He's everywhere! He's everywhere!
他无处不在！他无处不在！
The office of the police commissioner of Midland City.
米德兰市警察局长办公室。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃响]
Hello, this is the commissioner's--
喂，这里是局长办公室——
Ms. Helfinger, this is the winged-warrior.
海尔芬格女士，我是长翅膀的战士。
Yes, what is it?
好的，什么事？
Please inform the commissioner that I'm now all set for test sequence number one.
请告诉局长，我已经准备好进行一号测试程序了。
What?
什么？
It's all primed and ready to go.
一切准备就绪，可以开始了。
What are you talking about?
你在说什么？
The chicken missile, Ms. Helfinger.
“鸡弹”，海尔芬格女士。
The chicken missile?
“鸡弹”？
Yes, so tell the commissioner I'm ready for test sequence number one.
是的，所以告诉局长我准备好进行一号测试程序了。
Yes, Ms. Helfinger?
好的，海尔芬格女士？
Commissioner, the chicken missile is ready to go.
局长，鸡弹准备好发射了。
Huh?
啊？
The chicken missile.
鸡弹。
Oh, yes of course, the--
噢，对，没错，那个——
And it's ready for test sequence number one.
它已经准备好进行一号测试程序了。
Test sequence number one.
一号测试程序。
Number one.
一号。
Well, that's very nice. Very nice, yes.
嗯，那太好了。很好，是的。
Hello, winged-warrior?
喂，长翅膀的战士？
Right here, Ms. Helfinger.
在这儿，海尔芬格女士。
The commissioner said that's very nice.
局长说那太好了。
Oh fine, in that case, Ms. Helfinger, have the commissioner stand by with the chicken missile receiver.
噢，太好了，既然这样，海尔芬格女士，让局长守着鸡弹接收器。
What?
什么？
I'm going to count down.
我要开始倒数了。
Listen.
听着。
10, 9-- We'll see you at 14:00 hours.
10，9——我们14:00点见。
Hello, wa--
喂，长翅——
Yes, Ms. Helfinger?
是的，海尔芬格女士？
Commissioner, if I would say to you, prepare the chicken missile receiver, would you know?
局长，如果我要对您说，准备好鸡弹接收器，您知道怎么做吗？
No, I wouldn't.
不，我不知道。
I didn't think you would. Commissioner?
我就猜您不知道。局长？
Yes?
是的？
I would suggest that you crouch under your desk.
我建议您蹲在办公桌下面。
Crouch under my desk?
蹲在办公桌下面？
Yes, it should provide some protection.
是的，这应该能提供一点保护。
From--
从——
[CRASHING SOUNDS]
[撞击声]
--what?
——什么？
From the chicken missile.
从鸡弹那里保护你。
Wow. say, that chicken missile really works nifty. Will the Midland City fire department recommend that a chicken missile receive be installed in what's left of Midland City Hall? Be listening tomorrow for another exciting episode in the life of the most fantastic crime fighter the world has ever known, Chickenman.
哇，说真的，那枚鸡弹真的很厉害。米德兰市消防局会建议在剩下的米德兰市厅里安装一个鸡弹接收器吗？明天继续收听世界上最了不起的犯罪克星——鸡侠生命中又一段激动人心的插曲。
He's everywhere! He's everywhere!
他无处不在！他无处不在！
Well, coming up, life on a real turkey farm, David Sedaris, and, of course, the first new episode of Chickenman since the Nixon administration, written just for our program. That's all in a minute when our program continues.
好了，接下来，火鸡农场的生活，大卫·塞达里斯，当然，还有尼克松政府以来第一部鸡侠新剧，专门为我们节目创作的。所有内容一分钟后继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a topic, bring you documentaries, short fiction, found tape, anything we can think OF on that theme. Theme today, with the turkey of Thanksgiving just behind us, the turkey of Christmas ahead of us, we're in that turkey sandwich part of the year. And we are in the middle of it. We are at the center of that sandwich. And in honor of that, we're holding our annual poultry slam here on This American Life . This next story is from Julie Showalter, who grew up on a turkey farm in Missouri.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周节目里，我们都会设定一个主题，为你带来纪录片、短篇小说、发现的录音，或者任何我们能想到的关于这个主题的东西。今天的主题是，随着感恩节火鸡刚过去，圣诞节火鸡就在眼前，我们正处在这一年的“火鸡三明治”时期。我们正处于其中。我们正处在那个三明治的中心。为了纪念这一点，我们要在《美国生活》举办一年一度的家禽大满贯。下一个故事来自朱莉·肖沃尔特，她是在密苏里州的一个火鸡农场长大的。
The day before the night 3,000 thousand turkeys died, we moved 13,000 turkeys to the range. This requires some explanation. Turkeys spend their first 16 weeks in a heated brooder house. Then, they are put outside to range in fenced enclosures. Usually, men in trucks come and take them to the range at night. This time, daddy decided we'd herd them ourselves.
在3000只火鸡死掉的前一天晚上，我们把13000只火鸡移到了牧场。这需要解释一下。火鸡前16周是在加热的育雏室里度过的。然后，它们被放到围栏围起来的牧场里。通常，男人们会开车在晚上把它们运到牧场。这一次，爸爸决定让我们自己放牧。
It looked simple enough. We made a temporary chute of wire fencing that ran from the double-end doors of the brooder house 50 yards to the pen. We would get behind the turkeys in the brooder house, shout, wave old shirts and gunny sacks at them, and they would run out the doors, through the chute and into the pen. And that's the way it worked in the first brooder house. The first turkeys hesitated at the door, walked out cautiously, then moved through the chute and dispersed. The rest followed. It took about an hour. Daddy was pleased. "Let's work straight through, he said. "We'll be done by 10:00."
看起来很简单。我们用铁丝围栏做了一个临时滑道，从育雏室的双开门通向50码外的围栏。我们站在育雏室里火鸡的后面，大喊大叫，挥舞旧衬衫和麻袋，它们就会跑出门口，穿过滑道进入围栏。第一个育雏室就是这样操作的。第一批火鸡在门口犹豫了一下，谨慎地走出来，然后穿过滑道散开。剩下的跟了上来。大约花了一个小时。爸爸很高兴。“我们要一鼓作气干完，”他说，“10点前就能干完。”
By the time turkeys have been in a brooder house for 16 weeks, the air is filled with ammonia, feather particles and dust. The stench is overwhelming. After an hour in the brooder house, your lungs hurt for a day. You can contract disabling lung diseases from working only a week in a poultry house. Tiny barbed pieces of feather dig into the tissue of your lung and never let go. But we didn't know that then.
当火鸡在育雏室里呆了16周后，空气中充满了氨气、羽毛碎屑和灰尘。恶臭令人窒息。在育雏室呆上一小时后，肺部会疼上一整天。仅在禽舍工作一周，就可能感染致残的肺病。羽毛上细小的倒刺会扎进肺部组织，永远出不来。但那时我们不知道。
We moved the temporary fence to the doors of the second brooder house. When we threw open the doors at the end of the second house, it was 9:00 in the morning. The sun streamed in the open doors on turkeys that had never seen direct sunlight. The one thing you can count on with turkeys is that you never know how they are going to react. I've seen turkeys clamor against a fence trying to get into a range fire. I've seen them rush toward a screaming child trying to kill it, and I've seen them run from a screaming child spooked and terrified.
我们把临时围栏移到了第二个育雏室的门口。当我们在早上9点打开第二个房子的门时，阳光直射在从未见过直射阳光的火鸡身上。关于火鸡，你唯一能指望的就是你永远不知道它们会有什么反应。我见过火鸡在围栏上争先恐后地想冲进牧场的火堆里。我见过它们冲向尖叫的孩子想杀了他，也见过它们被尖叫的孩子吓得魂飞魄散逃跑。
These turkeys didn't want to go into the sun. As we pushed from behind, they compacted. It was like an old adventure movie where the walls are closing in, but there was no wall at the end, only a patch of sunlight, which the turkeys would not touch. We yelled louder, waved our cloths, kicked at the ones in the rear. Finally, Daddy walked through the solid carpet of turkeys to break the logjam at the front. He stood at the edge of the sunlight, lifting the turkeys three or four at a time with his feet, stirring them with his legs, forcing them into the sun.
这些火鸡不想进阳光里。当我们从后面推时，它们聚在一起。这就像老冒险电影里墙壁向中间靠拢的场景，但尽头没有墙，只有一块它们不敢触碰的阳光。我们更大声地叫喊，挥舞布料，踢后面的火鸡。最后，爸爸穿过密集的火鸡毯，打破了前面的僵局。他站在阳光的边缘，一次用脚拨开三四只火鸡，用腿搅动它们，强行把它们赶进阳光里。
Suddenly, they broke free. As stubbornly as they had refused to go into the light, they now rushed toward it. They ran in a panic, piling on top of each other, knocking down the temporary fence. By the time daddy could get the doors closed, at least 1,000 turkeys had escaped and were running free on the farm, onto our neighbor's farm, into the road.
突然，它们挣脱了束缚。就像之前拒绝进入光里一样执拗，它们现在冲向光。它们惊慌失措地奔跑，挤在一起，撞倒了临时围栏。等爸爸关上门时，至少有1000只火鸡逃跑了，在农场里、邻居家农场里、公路上到处奔跑。
We didn't own the turkeys. We raised them for a company that owned the hatchery, the feed mill, the fleet of trucks that delivered and loaded the turkeys, the processing plant. We got a portion of the profits, if there were profits. With 1,000 turkeys gone, there would be no profits on this flock. 16 weeks of daddy working 14-hour days, of my sisters and me working alongside him anytime we weren't in school, all for no pay. And if we weren't paid for this flock, we would have no cash coming in until the next flock was raised.
这些火鸡不是我们的。我们是为一家拥有孵化场、饲料厂、运载火鸡的卡车车队和加工厂的公司养殖的。如果盈利，我们能分到一部分利润。丢了1000只火鸡，这群鸡就不会有利润了。爸爸16周每天工作14小时，我妹妹们和我只要不上学就和他一起工作，所有这些都是无偿的。如果我们这群鸡拿不到钱，在下一群鸡养大之前，我们将没有任何现金收入。
It took us eight hours to round up the escaped turkeys, four of us trying to track down 1,000 birds that had the whole world in which to hide and run from us. The sun beat down, and the air was thick and humid. We stopped once for water, and my sister Billie, the youngest of us, just 11, vomited from the cold water hitting her stomach after hours of sun, heat, and dehydration. As she lay on the ground, shaking and holding her stomach, I hated her for being the one too sick to continue. But even she was not too sick. We all went on. She got an extra five minutes to rest, but we all went on.
我们花了八个小时才把逃跑的火鸡找回来，我们四个人试图追踪1000只鸟，它们有整个世界可以躲藏和逃离我们。太阳炙烤着，空气潮湿而粘稠。我们停下来喝过一次水，我妹妹比莉，我们中最小的，才11岁，因为在阳光下暴晒、炎热和脱水后喝下冷水而呕吐了。当她躺在地上颤抖、捂着肚子时，我恨她，恨她是那个太虚弱而无法继续下去的人。但即使她也并非真的不行。我们都继续前行。她得到了额外的五分钟休息时间，但我们都坚持了下来。
You may be asking right now how my father could be so cruel, how he could work young girls like that. Or you may think I'm exaggerating, that self-pity has magnified our distress. I tell you, this is no exaggeration. And I tell you, my father had no choice. Or any choice he had was so far in the past that there was no unraveling it. Years later, when we were grown, we caught a glimpse of his guilt, his bitterness over what he had done to us. "I couldn't afford niggers," he told my sister Billie, "so I had daughters."
你现在可能在问，我父亲怎么能这么残忍，怎么能这样奴役幼小的女儿。或者你可能认为我在夸大其词，认为自怜放大了我们的痛苦。我告诉你，这绝非夸张。我也告诉你，我父亲别无选择。或者他拥有的任何选择都已是过去太久的事情，无法挽回了。多年后，当我们长大成人，我们瞥见了他的愧疚和对他对自己所作所为的苦涩。“我请不起黑人，”他告诉妹妹比莉，“所以我有女儿。”
At 6 o'clock, we rebuilt the chute. We opened the doors, and the 6,000 remaining turkeys, the sun now low behind them, walked through to the pen. We cleaned up, we ate supper, and we went to bed. That's the day we had before the night 3,000 turkeys died. At midnight, mother woke us up. "We have to get to the pen. Daddy needs us." We had been too exhausted to hear the storm. We ran out in the driving rain. Flashes of lightning showed daddy picking up turkeys and throwing them one after the other.
6点钟，我们重建了滑道。我们打开大门，剩下的6000只火鸡，太阳现在落在了它们身后，走进了围栏。我们打扫干净，吃了晚饭，去睡觉了。那就是3000只火鸡死掉的前一天。午夜，母亲叫醒了我们。“我们得去围栏那边。爸爸需要我们。”我们太累了，没听见风暴的声音。我们跑进倾盆大雨中。闪电的光芒映照出爸爸抓起火鸡一只接一只地扔出去。
When people learn I grew up on a turkey farm, they invariably ask, "Is it true? Are they really so stupid that they open their mouths in the rain, look up at the sky, and drown?" The answer is yes. Some of them do that. They are that stupid. But that's not how 3,000 die in one night. They die because they are scared, and they huddle together in their fear. They climb on top of each other trying to get close, to find protection in the mass of bodies. And they suffocate. We called it piling.
当人们知道我是在火鸡农场长大的时，他们总是问：“这是真的吗？它们真的蠢到在大雨中张开嘴看着天空把自己淹死吗？”答案是肯定的。有些确实会那样。它们就是那么蠢。但那并不是3000只鸡一晚上死掉的原因。它们死是因为它们害怕，它们在恐惧中挤在一起。它们试图爬到对方身上以求靠近，试图在尸体堆中寻求保护。然后它们窒息了。我们称之为“堆叠”。
It wasn't unusual for a loud noise to cause a pile in the brooder house. If there wasn't someone to pull them off each other, 50 could die because someone slammed a door. But this was worse than any pile we'd seen. Turkeys who'd never spent a night outdoors, panicked by thunder and lightning and rain in sheets. All we could do was pull them out of the pile and throw them away from it. They would run back, still seeking the comfort of the group. After a while, standing in mud, grabbing soaked turkeys, throwing them, grabbing some more, you don't know if the ones you are throwing are dead or alive. You don't care. Maybe we saved some.
育雏室里因为巨大的噪音引发堆叠并不罕见。如果没有人把它们拉开，因为有人砰地关上门，50只鸡就可能死掉。但这次比我们见过的任何一次堆叠都严重。火鸡从未在户外过夜，被雷电和倾盆大雨吓坏了。我们能做的只是把它们从堆叠中拉出来，扔到远处。它们又跑回来，仍在寻求群体的安慰。过了一会儿，站在泥里，抓着湿透的火鸡，扔掉它们，再抓一些，你不知道你扔的那些是死是活。你不在乎。也许我们救了一些。
The next day, the sky was cloudless, and the sun bore down on us again. We picked up dead turkeys, throwing them onto the back of a flatbed truck. Daddy drove the truck into a field far from the house. 3,000 dead turkeys sitting in the Missouri sun for two days. The company that owned the turkeys had them insured against acts of God, so we couldn't do anything until the insurance inspector had seen them. He came, a man from town in a white shirt and tie who held his handkerchief over his face when he got close to the truck. He made no pretense of counting, just stood there gagging.
第二天，天空万里无云，太阳又炙烤着我们。我们捡起死掉的火鸡，扔到平板卡车的后面。爸爸把车开到离房子很远的田野里。3000只死火鸡在密苏里州的阳光下暴晒了两天。拥有这些火鸡的公司给它们买了保险，防范天灾，所以我们在保险检查员看到它们之前什么也做不了。他来了，一个从镇上来的穿白衬衫系领带的男人，走近卡车时捂着鼻子。他没有假装数数，只是站在那里干呕。
After he left, Daddy shoveled the turkeys into Dead Turkey Gulch. He poured gasoline on them and struck a match. They burned for days.
他走后，爸爸把火鸡铲进“死火鸡峡谷”。他浇上汽油，划了根火柴。它们烧了几天。
Julie Showalter lives in the Chicago area. She says she still eats turkey twice a year. She's just finished a novel called Needlework and is looking for a publisher.
朱莉·肖沃尔特住在芝加哥地区。她说她一年还是吃两次火鸡。她刚完成一部名为《针线活》的小说，正在寻找出版商。
Well, David Sedaris is a commentator on NPR'S Morning Edition , the author of the book, Barrel Fever and the forthcoming book, Naked. And he contributed the following story to our poultry slam. It's an excerpt from his diaries.
大卫·塞达里斯是美国国家公共电台《早间版》的评论员，也是《桶装热病》的作者，以及即将出版的《赤身裸体》一书的作者。他为我们的“家禽大满贯”贡献了下面这个故事。这是他日记的节选。
July 19, 1992. This afternoon at the 26th Street flea market, I had one of those experiences that remind me why I shop in the first place. Not shop like grocery shop, but step out into the world searching for that one thing I cannot name. I pass the usual objects, the grinning mammies offering themselves up as salt and pepper shakers, the coffee table made from dice, another head carved from a coconut. "That's collectible," the dealers say, referring to an ashtray in the shape of a doll-sized toilet bowl. Collectible to who?
1992年7月19日。今天下午在第26街跳蚤市场，我有了那种让我记起当初为什么去购物的经历。不是那种去杂货店买东西，而是走进世界，去寻找那种我说不出名字的东西。我路过常见的那些物品，那些做成盐和胡椒瓶的咧嘴笑的黑人保姆雕像，用骰子做的咖啡桌，另一个从椰子上雕刻出来的头。“那有收藏价值，”交易商说，指着一个马桶形状的烟灰缸说。对谁有收藏价值？
Last weekend at the flea market, I saw this thing, a taxidermy turkey's head attached to its own foot. This turkey was equipped with that length of flesh that spills from the top of its beak and fell to its neck. Stiff red hair stood out from the head and shoulders, and the claws were really sharp. You'd think that something armed like that might be able to protect itself. I pictured its maker standing by a chopping block saying, "I know. I'll take the turkey's head and attach it to the foot." Why would you do that? And more importantly, what sort of life would you lead that might enable you to make this connection?
上周末在跳蚤市场，我看到了这个东西，一个动物标本火鸡头，连着它自己的一只脚。这只火鸡装备着那种从鸟喙上方溢出并垂到脖子的肉质长条。僵硬的红发从头部和肩膀上竖起，爪子真的非常锋利。你会觉得拥有这种武装的东西应该能保护自己。我脑海中浮现出它的制作者站在案板旁说：“我知道了。我要把火鸡头割下来连到脚上。”你为什么要那么做？更重要的是，你需要过什么样的生活才能让你做出这种连接？
I was hypnotized by this object and asked the price as if I were under a spell. "$45," the dealer said. My tongue was dry from hanging in the open air, and I tried to fit it back into my mouth. "All right," she said, "35, 30." But she could have gone up. "All right, 85, 120, 370." I had no choice but to follow wherever she led me. I handed over my wallet in a trance, just gave it to her, thinking she could take the whole thing, the cash, blank checks, library card, whatever. Take it all. I stared into the face of this taxidermied turkey's head and nothing else mattered.
我被这个东西催眠了，问价时就像中了咒语一样。“45美元，”交易商说。我的舌头因为一直张着嘴而发干，我试着把它缩回嘴里。“好吧，”她说，“35，30。”但她本可以涨价的。“好吧，85，120，370。”我别无选择，只能跟着她指引的方向走。我如痴如醉地交出钱包，直接给了她，心想她可以把一切都拿走，现金、空白支票、借书证，什么都行。全部拿走吧。我凝视着这个动物标本火鸡头的脸，除此之外什么都不重要。
Tomorrow, what's that? Yesterday doesn't count. My life began the moment I could call this thing my own. On the way home, I felt giddy and confident that I could approach anyone at all and say, "I'll give you 100, no $500,000 if you can guess what I've got in this paper sack." And I swear that not one of them could have come up with the right answer. I walked home 30 blocks, looking everyone square in the eye and thinking, "Sucker."
明天？那是什么？昨天不算数。我的生活从我能称这个东西为我有物的那一刻开始。回家的路上，我感到头晕目眩，自信满满，我可以走过去对任何人说：“只要你能猜出我这纸袋里装的是什么，我给你100块，不，50万美元。”我发誓他们中没一个人能猜对。我走了30个街区回家，直视每个人的眼睛，心想：“傻瓜。”
David Sedaris lives in New York City. The stage adaptation of his SantaLand Diaries is now at the Atlantic Theater in Manhattan.
大卫·塞达里斯住在纽约。他的《圣兰日记》舞台改编版目前正在曼哈顿的大西洋剧院上演。
Thank you for calling WBEZ radio. Our offices are closed to observe the holiday. If you know your--
感谢致电WBEZ电台。我们的办公室现已关闭以庆祝假期。如果您知道您的——
[DIALING]
[拨号]
Please enter your mailbox number.
请输入您的邮箱号码。
[DIALING]
[拨号]
Please enter your security code.
请输入您的安全码。
[DIALING]
[拨号]
Greeting is on. You have one new and one saved message. To listen, press five.
问候语已开启。您有一条新信息和一条已保存信息。收听请按五。
[DIALING]
[拨号]
Hi, Ira, this is Michael in South Africa. Listen, about the item that we spoke about, the turkey's head attached to the turkey's foot, well, I spoke to some sangomas, which are witch doctors in the neighborhood about that thing. And they've never heard of anything quite like it or seen anything quite like it. However, when I would describe it to them, their jaws dropped. But look, I discovered a whole bunch about poultry in South Africa, so call me back, OK?
嗨，艾拉，我是南非的迈克尔。听着，关于我们谈到的那件东西，那个连着脚的火鸡头，我问了一些桑格玛，就是我们这儿的巫医，关于那个东西。他们以前从未听说过或见过类似的东西。然而，当我向他们描述它时，他们惊得下巴都掉了。但听着，我在南非发现了很多关于家禽的事情，所以给我回电话，好吗？
Well, Michael is Michael Stumm, performer, actor, former member of The Wooster Group in New York City. A former Chicagoan, now lives in Johannesburg, South Africa. And I asked him to look into the uses of chicken and other poultry among the sangoma culture in South Africa. Sangomas, or witch doctors or herbalists or orators, you hear them called sometimes, they're common in South Africa. Everybody seems to know one. And chickens are one of their main tools.
迈克尔是迈克尔·斯图姆，表演者、演员，纽约伍斯特剧团的前成员。曾住芝加哥，现住南非约翰内斯堡。我请他调查一下南非桑格玛文化中对鸡和其他禽类的使用情况。桑格玛，或称巫医、草药师或演说家，有时你会听到这么叫，在南非很普遍。每个人似乎都认识一个。鸡是他们主要工具之一。
Well, it's a funny thing. I've discovered that over half the country is just awash in chicken blood. It's a substance that comes in so handy. It's rather like-- gosh, I don't know-- it flows like milk does in America or Dr. Bronner's chamomile soap or some other easily spilled liquid in modern America. It's an incredibly versatile product. You can lose bad luck with it. You can strengthen a faulty muscle with it. You can improve your eyesight with it. You can find lost items with it. You can get your wife back with it. You can transfer your bad luck to someone else with it.
嗯，这很有趣。我发现这个国家的一半地区到处都是鸡血。这是一种很方便的物质。它有点像——天哪，我不知道——它像美国的牛奶、布朗纳博士的甘菊皂，或者现代美国其他容易洒出的液体那样流动。这是一种令人难以置信的多功能产品。你可以用它消除厄运。你可以用它强健虚弱的肌肉。你可以用它改善视力。你可以用它找回丢失的物品。你可以用它挽回妻子的心。你可以用它把厄运转移到别人身上。
I mean, I had someone tell me that there is a ceremony involving the killing of a chicken in a rather baroque manner, which I'll describe to you. But this is a very specific ceremony that involved losing your court papers at court.
我是说，有人告诉我有一种仪式涉及以一种相当华丽的方式杀鸡，我会为你描述的。但这是一种非常具体的仪式，涉及让你在法庭上丢失你的诉讼文件。
In other words, if you do this thing with this chicken, the court will lose the papers, and that's how you will go free?
换句话说，如果你对这只鸡做了这件事，法院就会丢失文件，你就可以因此无罪释放？
Allow me to describe the ceremony.
请允许我描述这个仪式。
Sure, because I'm sure many of our listeners get into these kinds of situations and have wondered, how can we make, for example, the US District Attorney simply lose that file?
当然，因为我相信许多听众都会陷入这种境地，并想知道，我们如何能让美国联邦检察官直接丢失那个档案？
Yeah, you are arrested. A court date is set. You then go home to your witch doctor. You bring him a white chicken. It has to be a white chicken. The witch doctor then prescribes some muti, which is medicine. It can come in many, many forms. Perhaps it's a powder. Perhaps it's a liquid. It doesn't really matter because you're going to take the muti yourself. You then take the chicken and the muti to the nearest mountain. You climb to the top of the mountain. You dig a hole. You dig a hole large enough for the chicken to fit in. You then speak to the chicken. You say to the chicken, "This is what I want to have happen. I would like my United States federal court tax document, file number 869102b, to disappear." Or whatever it is that you want to disappear.
是的，你被逮捕了。法庭日期定下来了。然后你回家找你的巫医。你带给他一只白鸡。必须是白鸡。巫医然后开出一些“穆蒂”，就是药。它可以有很多很多种形式。也许是粉末，也许是液体。这没关系，因为你自己要服用那个穆蒂。然后你带着鸡和穆蒂去最近的山。你爬到山顶。你挖一个洞。挖一个足够装下那只鸡的洞。然后你对鸡说话。你对鸡说：“这就是我想要发生的。我想要我的美国联邦法院税务文件，档案号869102b，消失。”或者任何你想要消失的东西。
You then take a large sewing needle, and you poke the chicken's eyes out with this sewing needle. You then bury the chicken, the now blind chicken, alive in the hole. You put him in the hole. You put the dirt back on.
然后你拿一根大缝衣针，用这根针把鸡的眼睛戳瞎。然后你把那只鸡，那只现在眼瞎的鸡，活着埋进洞里。把它放进洞里。把土盖回去。
Then this chicken is going to do something for you in the afterworld after you've poked out its eyes and you're burying it alive? This chicken is going to do you a favor among the mystic spirits?
那这只鸡在你戳瞎它的眼睛并把它活埋之后，会在来世为你做什么？这只鸡会在神秘灵魂之间为你提供帮助吗？
Magic is funny, Ira. What can I say? Essentially, it's the end of the ceremony. You leave the chicken, and then you go. And as it was described to me, you go back to your court date on the day of your court date, and your papers will be lost. People will say to you, "You have no papers. You are free." That's how it was described to me.
魔法很有趣，艾拉。我能说什么呢？基本上，仪式到此结束。你把鸡留在那里，然后就走了。正如人们对我描述的那样，你在开庭之日回到法庭，你的文件就会丢失。人们会告诉你：“你没有任何文件。你是自由的。”这就是人们向我描述的情况。
Now, Mr. Stumm, in the interest of accurate reporting, have you talked to anyone who claims that this worked for them personally?
那么，斯图姆先生，出于准确报道的考虑，你有没有和任何人谈过，他们声称这真的对他们个人有效？
Well, the gentleman I spoke to has heard of this working. He has not actually been arrested himself and caused his papers to disappear in this manner. But apparently, there are gangs of chicken rustlers here, not unlike cattle rustling in Western movies.
嗯，我谈过的那位先生听说过这真的有效。他本人并没有被逮捕过，也没有用这种方式让自己的文件消失。但显然，这里有成群的“鸡窃贼”，就像西部片里的偷牛贼一样。
You're making this up.
你在胡扯。
Cattle rustlers.
偷牛贼。
Chicken rustlers.
鸡窃贼。
Chicken rustlers, I swear.
鸡窃贼，我发誓。
What kind of dignity is there in that for a man? Let me just ask you that.
作为一个男人，那有什么尊严可言？我只想问你。
Chicken rustling?
偷鸡？
Yeah, you rustle some cattle, and you feel like a man. But you rustle a chicken, I mean, the word rustle doesn't even seem like it's the right word. It's just too big a word. It's too grand a word. You don't hear the strands of Aaron Copland when the word rustle comes up next to the word chicken. Hold on for a second. I'm just going to put on some Aaron Copland here right now. I just wanted you to conjure a scene of the chicken rustlers. Could you just describe how you picture them? The music is going now.
是啊，你偷牛，感觉像个男人。但你偷鸡，我是说，连“偷”这个词听起来都不太对。这个词太大了。太宏大了。当你把偷这个词和鸡连在一起时，你听不到阿隆·科普兰音乐的旋律。等等，我现在就要放点阿隆·科普兰的音乐。我只是想让你想象一下偷鸡贼的场景。你能描述一下你眼中的他们吗？音乐正在播放。
Well, I think as I picture a chicken rustle, they probably wait until the sun goes down. And they probably have a sack, because if you stick a chicken in a sack, she is not going to make noise. So they probably chuck a bunch of chickens in the sack, as many as they can get away with until the chickens who are not in the sack start making noise. And then they run away. That's how I envision a chicken rustling.
嗯，我想在我想象中的偷鸡过程中，他们大概会等到天黑。他们大概会有一个麻袋，因为如果你把鸡塞进麻袋里，它就不会发出噪音。所以他们大概会把一大堆鸡塞进麻袋里，能拿多少就拿多少，直到还没进麻袋的鸡开始发出噪音。然后他们就跑了。这就是我设想的偷鸡场景。
Michael, do chicken rustlers ever get rustled themselves? I mean is it like the mafia, where it goes back and forth and back and forth in an endless cycle of violence and rustling?
迈克尔，鸡窃贼会被别人偷吗？我是说，这就像黑手党，暴力和偷窃没完没了的循环吗？
Luca Brasi sleeps with the chickens. I don't know.
卢卡·布拉西和鸡一起睡。我不知道。
Act Five, Chickenman, Like the Phoenix. As a child, I did not care about the radio. In fact, I have to say that there was only one thing that I remember hearing on the radio up until the age of 16, I'd say. And that was Chickenman. It had all these qualities of radio that I've since come to value. It was surprising. It was funny. It had its own sound, a sound that was completely distinctive and instantly recognizable and appealing. Dick Orkin was the voice of Chickenman, and in the years since Chickenman, he's done tons of work, including lots of commercials in that deadpan style, a style which hundreds of people all over the country have tried to imitate. Nobody ever gets it right.
第五幕，鸡侠，如凤凰涅槃。小时候，我不关心广播。事实上，不得不说，在我16岁之前，我记得在收音机里听到的东西只有一样，那就是鸡侠。它具备了我后来所珍视的所有广播品质。它出人意料。它很有趣。它有自己的声音，一种完全独特、瞬间可辨且迷人的声音。迪克·奥金是鸡侠的配音，在鸡侠之后的岁月里，他做了大量工作，包括许多那种冷面幽默风格的广告，全国成百上千人试图模仿这种风格。从来没有人模仿得对。
And it's a pleasure, it's an honor to have him on our program. Last year when This American Life was just a local program in Chicago, before you could hear it around the country, we invited Dick Orkin to create a new Chickenman episode for our Poultry Slam. And he put a cast together, put together the first new episode since 1969. In this episode, Chickenman is a quarter century older, like his creator, and he faces a new set of problems.
很高兴、很荣幸能请他上我们的节目。去年当《美国生活》还只是芝加哥当地的一档节目，在你能在全国范围内听到它之前，我们邀请迪克·奥金为我们的“家禽大满贯”创作了一部新的鸡侠剧集。他召集了一个演员阵容，完成了1969年以来的第一部新剧集。在这一集中，鸡侠和他的创作者一样，老了四分之一个世纪，他面临着一系列新的问题。
Now, another exciting episode in the life of the most fantastic crime fighter the world has ever known, Chickenman.
现在，世界上最了不起的犯罪克星——鸡侠生命中又一段激动人心的插曲。
He's everywhere! He's everywhere!
他无处不在！他无处不在！
Tuesday morning, 9:30 AM. The chicken alarm in my chicken cave goes off 30 minutes late, which makes me late for my annual physical at my doctor, [? Dupont ?] Chopper. I didn't want to be late since it was my first in 30 years. 9:50 AM. I get a flat as I pull the chicken Coupe out of the chicken garage. So I take the convenient number 32 bus, which drops me off only 14 blocks from the doctor's office.
周二早上，9:30。我鸡窟里的鸡报警器晚了30分钟才响，这让我去医生那里的年度体检迟到了。我不想迟到，因为这是我30年来的第一次体检。9:50。我把鸡轿车开出鸡库时爆胎了。所以我坐了方便的32路公交车，它把我放在离医生办公室只有14个街区的地方。
You're late. You're late for a very important date.
你迟到了。你迟到了，错过了一个非常重要的约会。
Says the doctor, and I say, "I know. I'm sorry. All the air went out of my whatchamacallit."
医生说，我说：“我知道。对不起。我的那个什么什么东西全没气了。”
That happens to all of us. Age. Try not to sit on sharp things, and don't think sharp things.
这种情况我们都有。年纪大了。尽量不要坐在尖锐的东西上，也不要思考尖锐的东西。
OK.
好的。
Body, mind, mind body in all you do. And Santa Claus is watching you.
身体，头脑，头脑带动身体，做你所做的一切。圣诞老人正在看着你。
11:00 AM, after several tests and poking and prodding.
11:00 AM，经过几次测试和戳戳点点后。
Well, your cholesterol is a little high. The pain in your toes is arthritis, and I think you have the beginning of a nice hernia.
嗯，你的胆固醇有点高。脚趾的疼痛是关节炎，我想你开始长了一个漂亮的疝气。
Cholesterol high, I had no idea.
胆固醇高，我完全不知道。
Well, technically it's not high because one, it is in your mind. And two, it is your bad cholesterol that's bad. Your good cholesterol is not good, but in time, your cholesterol will be good, and your good cholesterol will be bad. And that's not good.
嗯，严格来说它不高，因为第一，它在你的脑子里。第二，这是你的坏胆固醇，确实不好。你的好胆固醇也不好，但久而久之，你的胆固醇会变好，你的好胆固醇会变坏。这可不好。
Anything else?
还有什么吗？
Yes, you are ugly.
是的，你很丑。
That's my chicken mask, the beak and the feathers.
那是我的鸡面具，鸟喙和羽毛。
Anybody ever tell you it's ugly?
有人跟你说过它很丑吗？
Well, that's the idea. Otherwise, I couldn't strike terror into the hearts of vicious criminals everywhere.
嗯，这正是目的所在。否则我就无法让各地恶贯满盈的罪犯闻风丧胆了。
Aha, well don't look at small children or animals. Anyway, that's the health story, but I don't think you have to alter your lifestyle unless you are a crime-fighting superhero of some kind. [LAUGHS] Want to buy one of my tapes?
啊哈，好吧，别看着小孩或动物。总之，这就是健康方面的情况，但除非你是某种打击犯罪的超级英雄，否则我觉得你没必要改变生活方式。[笑]想买我的磁带吗？
12:00 noon. I return to the chicken cave, and there in the chicken mirror-- ah!-- I see something horrible. No, not my ugly face, my own mortality. I ask myself why it never stared me in the face before. After all, I've been fighting crime and or evil for over 30 years, pursuing it down streets and alleys and sewers and other picturesque places, and my mortality never came up even once.
12:00 中午。我回到鸡窟，在那里，在鸡镜子里——啊！——我看到了可怕的东西。不，不是我那张丑脸，而是我自己的死亡。我问自己为什么以前从未直面过它。毕竟，我已经打击犯罪或邪恶30多年了，在街道、小巷、下水道和其他如画的地方追捕它们，而我的死亡甚至一次都没出现过。
1:40 PM. I go see the police commissioner and share with him the doctor's diagnosis. After all, he is my closest friend, and if I can't tell him the bad news, who can I tell? So I give him a new coloring book I bought for him and tell him my sad news. And he says--
1:40 PM。我去见警察局长，与他分享医生的诊断结果。毕竟，他是我最好的朋友，如果我不能把坏消息告诉他，我还能告诉谁呢？所以我给了他一本我买给他的新涂色书，并告诉他我的坏消息。他说——
Uh-huh. This looks like a real neat coloring book.
嗯哼。这看起来像是一本非常漂亮的涂色书。
So what do you think, Commissioner?
所以你怎么看，局长？
About what?
关于什么？
What I just shared with you?
我刚才跟你分享的事情？
Oh, it's a real neat coloring book.
噢，这是一本非常漂亮的涂色书。
About the diagnosis and the need to alter my lifestyle.
关于诊断结果以及我需要改变生活方式的必要性。
Oh, well that would mean that you'd have to-- and of course one cant even be sure that, you know-- so anyway that's how I see it.
噢，嗯，那意味着你将不得不——当然，没人能确定，你知道——所以，这就是我的看法。
OK, thanks, Commissioner.
好的，谢谢你，局长。
Anytime, winged warrior. After all, what are friends for? And may I ask you a question?
随时欢迎，长翅膀的战士。毕竟，朋友是干什么的呢？我可以问你一个问题吗？
OK.
好的。
If I make the sky blue in this picture and the mountains brown, do you think the rocks should be chartreuse?
如果我把这张画里的天空涂成蓝色，山涂成棕色，你觉得岩石应该涂成黄绿色吗？
Perfect. 4:00 PM. I go to the local office of the Gracehill Fergus employment agency and screen door company.
完美。4:00 PM。我去当地的格雷斯希尔·弗格斯职业介绍所和纱门公司。
OK, when you say something more sed-rentary like what do you mean?
好吧，当你提到“更沉静一点”的工作时，你是什么意思？
No, sedentary you know, things where I can seden--sit.
不，是久坐不动（sedentary），你知道，可以让我坐着的工作。
Oh, OK, so something sit-entary.
噢，好的，所以是“坐着”工作。
Yeah.
是啊。
I just started here. I'm supposed to ask some questions. What kind of previous work experience do you have?
我刚来这儿。我得问几个问题。你以前有什么工作经验？
Basically fighting crime and or evil.
基本上是打击犯罪或邪恶。
OK, and what special equipment, office or otherwise, are you experienced in using?
好的，你擅长使用什么特殊的办公设备或其他设备吗？
Geshtukana ray gun.
格什图卡纳光线枪。
Could you spell that?
你能拼写一下吗？
G-E-S-H-T-U-K-N-A. And I also worked a chicken dissolver and a chicken modulator and a can opener.
G-E-S-H-T-U-K-N-A。我还操作过鸡溶解器、鸡调制器和开罐器。
T-U-K--
T-U-K——
A-N-A. So what do you have in light work that I could do?
A-N-A。那么你们有什么我可以做的轻松工作吗？
A-N--
A-N——
A. That's it. Geshtukana. You got it?
A。就是这个。格什图卡纳。记住了吗？
OK, do you know Windows 95?
好的，你会用Windows 95吗？
Look, what light job openings are on your list there? Just look.
听着，你们清单上有什么轻松的工作岗位吗？看看就行。
Heavy cable puller, refrigerator and piano mover, cement hailer--
重型电缆牵引工、冰箱和钢琴搬运工、水泥拖运——
Hauler.
拖运（Hauler）。
OK. [SCREAMING] Big tree planter, circus tent.
好的。[尖叫]大树种植工、马戏团帐篷。
Miss, not holler. Those are all active and heavy things. Anything light I could do?
小姐，不是搬运（Holler）。那些都是活跃且繁重的活。有什么我可以做的轻松工作吗？
Yes, a negligee model in a delicatessen.
是的，熟食店的睡衣模特。
I don't wear--
我不穿——
Oh, well, scratch that then. Requires previous experience. Oh, here's something really perfect.
噢，好吧，那就算了。需要相关经验。噢，这儿有个完美的。
What's that?
什么？
A napkin folder in a nouveau Italian-Chinese restaurant specializing in pizza and light salads. Takeout available. Mmm, I'm hungry.
一家新派意大利-中国餐厅的餐巾折叠工，专门做比萨和清淡沙拉。可外带。唔，我饿了。
Wednesday morning, 9:30 AM. My chicken alarm goes off a half hour late for my geriatric counseling appointment. Tire still flat. So I take the convenient number 18 bus, and that leaves me off only 28 blocks from the counselor's office.
周三早上，9:30。我的鸡报警器又晚了半小时响，耽误了我的老年咨询预约。轮胎还是瘪的。所以我坐了方便的18路公交车，它把我放在离咨询师办公室只有28个街区的地方。
I have one word of advice, mister. Get out.
我有一句话要送给你，先生。出去。
Excuse me?
对不起？
Get out.
出去。
Do you mean from this office?
你是说离开这个办公室吗？
I mean get out. O-U-T.
我是说出去。O-U-T。
OK, I'm a few minutes late.
好吧，我迟到了几分钟。
You're 30 years too late. Get out.
你迟到了30年。出去。
Oh, you mean get out, not get out.
噢，你是说离开，不是那种“出去”。
May I suggest a small desert superhero retirement community. You play golf?
我可以建议一个小型的沙漠超级英雄退休社区吗？你打高尔夫球吗？
Not real good, no.
打得不太好，没。
Good, you'll fit right in. Neither does Fishwoman or that flying newt. I sent them there. They love it.
很好，你正合适。鱼女和那只飞蝾螈也不行。我把她们送去那儿了。她们很喜欢。
Fishwoman?
鱼女？
Yeah, a little scaly, nice personality.
是啊，身上有点鳞片，性格很好。
OK.
好的。
Want to buy one of my tapes?
想买我的磁带吗？
2:00 AM next morning. I can't sleep, and I sip warm milk in the chicken cave. What to do? I'm on the horns of a dilemma. Heavy concrete hauler? Fold napkins in nouveau Italian-Chinese restaurant specializing in pizza and light salads? Or challenge the fates?
第二天凌晨2:00。我睡不着，在鸡窟里喝着温牛奶。该怎么办？我陷入了进退两难的境地。重型水泥拖运工？在新派意大利-中国餐厅折叠餐巾？还是挑战命运？
8:00 AM. I stand on the roof of the Midland City's skyscraper, four dizzy stories high. I hurl a challenge to the fates. "This is the winged warrior, fates. I shall go on fighting crime and or evil. I don't care that my bad cholesterol is bad, that--" Suddenly, a black cloud forms swiftly in the sky, and I hear--
早上8:00。我站在米德兰市摩天大楼的楼顶，四层楼高。我向命运发出挑战。“我是长翅膀的战士，命运。我将继续打击犯罪或邪恶。我不在乎我的坏胆固醇很坏，不在乎——”突然，天空迅速形成一朵乌云，我听到——
OK, do what you want. We'll try to be there for you, but watch the fatty foods, the cookies, the ice cream, and good luck to you.
好吧，你想做什么就做什么吧。我们会试着支持你，但注意那些高脂肪食物、饼干、冰淇淋，祝你好运。
Who is that?
那是谁？
One of the fates.
其中一个命运。
Which one?
哪一个？
Frank. Phyllis, Fran, and Fred are in Las Vegas. God bless them. They should only win and be well.
弗兰克。菲利斯、弗兰和弗雷德在拉斯维加斯。上帝保佑她们。祝她们赢钱，身体健康。
OK, well, fine, I'll just carry on then.
好的，好吧，那我继续吧。
OK, listen, could you change that mask you're wearing? Now it's very ugly and could scare kids and small animals. Thank you very much.
好的，听着，你能换掉你戴的面具吗？现在它非常丑，可能会吓到小孩和动物。非常感谢。
Right. And at that moment, I knew fate was blind, and I, the famous fowl, would have the last laugh. For you see, I wasn't wearing a mask. [LAUGHS]
好吧。那一刻，我知道命运是盲目的，而我，著名的禽类，将笑到最后。因为你看，我根本没戴面具。[笑]
Well, what has the winged warrior gotten himself into here? Can he actually stop time by challenging the fates? And is it Frank Fate he's talking to or George Jessel? And another thing, doesn't that nouveau Italian-Chinese restaurant sound super trendy? Be listening tomorrow for another exciting episode in the life of the most fantastic crime fighter the world has ever known, Chickenman.
好了，长翅膀的战士把自己卷入了什么事里？他真的能通过挑战命运来停止时间吗？他是在跟弗兰克·命运说话，还是跟乔治·杰塞尔？还有，那家新派意大利-中国餐厅听起来不觉得超级时髦吗？明天继续收听世界上最了不起的犯罪克星——鸡侠生命中又一段激动人心的插曲。
He's everywhere! He's everywhere!
他无处不在！他无处不在！
Well, "Chickenman Challenges a Fate Named Frank" was recorded at Dick Orkin's radio ranch in Hollywood, California. Along with Dick Orkin, the cast included Allison Ann Martin, Miriam Flynn, Charlie Brill, and Jim Gallant. Engineers Elizabeth Lane and James [? Burns, ?] written by Dick Orkin and Christine Coyle. Miss Flynn's hairstyle by Mr. Bunny. If you want more information about Chickenman , it is on the internet with sound files that you can get at this address, www.radio-ranch.com.
“鸡侠挑战命运弗兰克”是在加州好莱坞迪克·奥金的广播牧场录制的。除了迪克·奥金，演员还包括艾莉森·安·马丁、米里亚姆·弗林、查理·布里尔和吉姆·加兰特。工程师伊丽莎白·莱恩和詹姆斯·伯恩斯，剧本由迪克·奥金和克里斯汀·科伊尔创作。弗林小姐的发型由邦尼先生设计。如果你想了解更多关于鸡侠的信息，可以在互联网上获取音频文件，地址是 www.radio-ranch.com。
Well, today's program was produced by Nancy Updike, Peter Clowney, Alix Spiegel, Dolores Wilber, and myself. Contributing editors Margy Rochlin, Paul Tough, and Jack Hitt.
好了，今天的节目由南希·厄普代克、彼得·克劳尼、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、多洛雷斯·威尔伯和我制作。特约编辑马吉·罗克林、保罗·塔夫和杰克·希特。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
I just want a real person who's like Duki probably. I want to go marry some guy who's like Duki.
我只是想要一个真正像杜基那样的人。我想嫁给一个像杜基一样的家伙。
And how is that search going?
那寻找进展如何？
Not well.
不怎么样。
If you'd like to buy a copy of this or any of our This American Life programs, they make a fine stocking stuffer. Christmas is coming up. Don't delay. Call us at WBEZ here in Chicago, 312-832-3380. 312-832-3380. The cost is $10.
如果你想买本节目或我们任何一期《美国生活》的副本，它们是很好的长筒袜填充礼物。圣诞节快到了。别耽误。请致电我们芝加哥的WBEZ电台，电话312-832-3380。312-832-3380。费用是10美元。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. I'm Ira Glass.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Ira, don't make me sound like an idiot, OK?
艾拉，别把我弄得像个白痴，好吗？
Done.
搞定。
Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
下周回来收听更多《美国生活》的故事。